You want to prove you're the GOAT?
This is your chance.
Yeah, yeah...no problem.
I mean, it's just Michael Jordan, right?
We must destroy that which stands in our way.
The Mediadel.
Don't show that kind of frustration
in front of Ser Jordan.
It's like blood in the water.
Wait, what? I...
Cut away all your distractions.
Cut away self-doubt
and insecurity.
Once you have removed all
that does not serve you in battle,
you have found your Mamba form.
My fellow gods of tomorrow,
we are
the Dream Team's nightmare!
Alright, Dream Team.
Welcome to my Eurostep!
Back screen! Back screen!
Where’s the foul? Where’s the foul?
James! You can’t flop!
Embiid’s having one of him lazy games.
Watch your back, Joel.
Do a 180! Do a 180!
Get that shit out of here!
Here we go, Process. Here we go!
How do you like the size of my hands?
Haha! Hey Larry, what do you think of this?
Wait, their big men…
they're shooting threes!
Their big men are rangers!
I’m drowning in Ewing’s sweat!
Someone get Mullin!
Ayy! I’m White Walkin' here!
A pass for you! A pass for you!
Watch Dell’s son!
Where’s the help?
Gobert, nice block!
Time for you to taste my invisible soup!
Are you seeing this?
This is the craziest battle I’ve ever seen!
Watch the Chainmail Man!
Who’s got the Chainmail Man?
My god, I’ve never seen so much strength!
Ref! Ref! His tunic’s untucked!
His tunic’s untucked!
You just got Processed.
This is for Toni Kukoc!
Ball don’t lie, bitch.
Watch Drexler! Watch Drexler!
Which one’s Drexler?
He’s like a...worse Jordan!
Watch Pippen!
Punch it! Punch it!
Chris, punch Pippen’s dong!
Ow.
Who’s on Jordan? Who’s got Jordan?
Touch his face, Rudy! Touch his face!
I touch his face!
YOU THINK THE PLAGUE BOTHERS ME?
HAHAHA!
He’s mine.
Oh LeBron, how I’ve waited for this…
Take it in.
Because this
is your LAST
LAST DANCE!
Good farmer!
Spare some wine for your GOAT?
Our goat don’t drink wine.
Heh.
I mean me.
King James.
The now undisputed greatest knight of all time.
Nah...
nobody's better than Michael Jordan.
Well, uh,
you know, I defeated him.
Saved the Realm,
no big deal.
Heh. OK.
Is that LeBron James?
Sure is.
Well, what’s he want?
Just a little celebratory wine is all.
He says he’s better than Ser Jordan.
It’s true actually.
Oh, come on.
Jordan's got six rings!
Yeah. Jordan’s a killer.
Never lost a Finals.
Says he beat him in some big battle.
OK, well, Jordan’s like 60,
so who gives a shit?
Well actually, he was in his prime
because he used magic Soul Box shards
on the Dream Team and…
Have you not heard of any of this?
No.
Well, check your highlight ravens.
Haven’t gotten any.
What about your local sports crier?
Nope.
No news or nothing.
Social media ravens have been down
for a while too.
Wait. So you’re telling me,
we just had the biggest, most epic battle
in the history of the Realm
and nobody heard about it?
Guess not.
What the–
Now THIS is great.
Finally we can just play basketball.
No blog boys around to criticize us.
We've got no haters in the stands.
Yeah...it’s um…
it's nice.
A bit boring, though.
Realm officials?
Ugh.
Everyone, just be cool.
Kyrie started it!
Yeah this was ALL Kyrie.
I don’t even know these dudes.
LeBron?
What have you done!?
You saved the Realm.
I liberated it.
You didn’t have to burn it all down.
You’ve destroyed everything.
The stats. The history. The stories…
the gossip, the ignorant critiques,
the unfounded trade rumors.
After all I’ve done for you!
I finally beat Ser Jordan
and now there’s no Mediadel to talk about it!
Ah, so that's what this is about?
That I’ve spoiled your coronation ceremony.
Don’t be fooled, Ser Anthony.
His whole selfless teammate act
is just that...
an act.
Behind those corny dad jokes
is an insatiable appetite for adoration.
Kyrie, you must understand that
with the Mediadel in shambles
there is nobody to generate interest in our battles.
Our ratings are dim.
Our economy is failing.
Every second a fanling isn’t obsessing on
Ben Simmons trade rumors
or RJ Barrett’s progress
is one they are spending exploring other passions
like science, philosophy,
or even worse,
spending time with their families.
What can I say?
I guess I ruined something else.
We’re going to have to
suspend you indefinitely for this.
But,
considering you are a star knight,
we would be willing to commute your sentence
if...
you and your crew of...
"grumpy boys"
agree to rebuild the Mediadel.
You’ve still got so much potential, Kyrie.
Don’t waste it sulking here in the dark.
Don’t tell me what to do.
I’m not your sidekick anymore.
Very well.
Burned down the Mediadel, eh?
What!? Hello?
I’ve burned a few things down in my day.
OK. Like what?
House Sixers.
Maester Hinkie?
How long have you been down here?
Oh, quite some time.
The only thing that sustains me is knowing that
somewhere, beyond those bars,
Joel Embiid,
Ben Simmons
and I assume Jayson Tatum
are now a dynasty.
Tell me,
how many championships have we won?
Um...
Oh, what I’d give
for the chance to show the world
I can do more than just burn things down.
Tell me about it.
Destruction is the easy part.
Any cynic can tear things down
and call themselves a genius,
but it takes a true visionary
to actually improve things,
to build a better world.
That’s the part
I was really looking forward to.
That’s the real challenge.
So now you want us to just rebuild this place?
What about your whole rant about haters?
I gotta say,
being in the dungeon for almost a day
really changed me.
I realized the haters are what fuel us.
Without conflict, there is no story.
And our Realm is as much about the stories
as the battles themselves.
OK, well…
also if we don’t rebuild this,
we won’t be rich anymore and
we’ll have to get real jobs.
-I'm in
-That sounds good
-Works for me
-You got it
So what do we do?
Russ, you throw up bricks from a distance.
Kevin, collect all your burners
and start repopulating the ravenry.
Draymond, you’re the guy
on the construction site that yells at everybody.
Jimmy,
you’re also that guy.
Boogie,
you’ll handle the engineering and blueprints.
Why me?
Because you’ve got vast experience with technicals.
Swamp Dragon,
you’ll be doing the welding.
And Melo,
you’re on the bench.
Oh, come on. I’m good again!
I gotta say, Kyrie,
I'm impressed.
This is a top-two Mediadel, all-time.
There’s one last thing to do.
All the books and histories of this Realm
were destroyed in the fire.
They must be rewritten.
Let the Truth fill these books.
Ladies and gentlemen of Balleros,
we are here to bestow upon King James
the most exalted title of
GOAT of GOATs.
For he hath led his knights to victory
against a foe once believed unbeatable,
the Dream Team.
In doing so
he defeated prime Michael Jordan,
earning him the title of
the greatest knight of all time.
Hashtag washed king, eh?
Thank you everyone,
but today isn’t really about me.
It’s about my teammates.
It’s about all the legends who came before me.
Of course the fanlings,
the Mediadel maesters
and the future GOATs who
may one day take this crown from me.
Thank you.
Corny!
Now, before we officially crown King James,
are there any objections?
Ehhhhhhhhhhhhh...
Are we sure he’s better than Jordan?
I mean...
you could make the case...
LeBron got lucky, you know?
Hear hear!
Yeah, I mean, I was at the battle,
and don’t get me wrong.
LeBron was incredible.
But…
it was only one battle.
Best of seven?
I’m putting my money on Jordan.
What?
I don't know.
I gotta disagree with you, Chuck.
I think now that these guys finally beat the Dream Team,
I think that's all the evidence I need to say that
the GOAT...
it's gotta be Tatum, right?
Right? It's gotta be Jayson Tatum.
What? Jayson Tatum?
Has everyone gone mad?
Where’s Nick Wright?
Think the dragon got him.
Now hold on, everyone.
I am lucky enough to witness
King James’ greatness,
night in and night out.
What he does at his age
is truly unprecedented.
Thank you.
That being said...
What?
One could argue...
he’s not even the best knight on his own team.
Well, now hold on.
The numbers cannot be denied.
I have amassed the most points
of any knight in history.
Also, six rings.
Five more and you can talk, child.
I have 11 reasons why I am the GOAT.
I would kick LeBron’s ass!
THIS DEBATE IS OVER.
I. AM. THE. GOAT.
But let me ask you this.
What does the word GOAT mean to you, anyway?
-This should be good.
-Kyrie’s gonna throw someone under the bus!
-Everyone shush, I want to hear this!
What makes a GOAT?
Is it the rings?
Is it the stats?
Is it the style?
No.
It’s the story.
There’s nothing more powerful
than a good story.
And who has a better story…
than Paul Pierce?
What?
Paul Pierce not only has a championship ring,
and was a 10-time All-Star,
but he did it all
after being stabbed.
He once hit a game-winning bank shot
and when asked if he called ‘bank,’
he said ‘I called game.’
A crippled man
who became the most interesting
maester in the Mediadel
when he had the courage to say
he was better than Dwyane Wade.
He's right!
Kyrie's right about something!
That shot over Al Harrington was all-time!
To Paul Pierce,
the true GOAT!
PAUL PIERCE! PAUL PIERCE! PAUL PIERCE!